i just have the greatest respect for
anybody that
has dedicated their lives to saving
other people's lives
and improving the health of their
patients and focusing
first and foremost on their patients so
i
really want to thank you for that i want
to thank you for taking the time to
prepare testimony and appear before us
in person
and via webex in our first hearing on
early treatment of kovid
dr peter mcculloch presented two slides
if we can bring the first one up here
the first slide showed the four pillars
of pandemic response
the first pillar is contagion control
and of course we've done that with
social distancing and
economic shutdowns mass all those types
of things
the second pillar is early home
treatment the third
is late stage hospital treatment and the
fourth is vaccination
if you want to put up the next slide
the second slide displayed the three
stages of
covet of the disease the first stage is
viral replication
the second cytokine storm and the third
micro thrombosis the goal this hearing
is identical
to the goal of our first hearing to
discuss
early treatment options that attack the
disease in the first stage
by limiting viral replication doing so
would hopefully prevent progression to
cytokine storm
microthrombos microthrombosis
and possibly death this is how tamiflu
works in limiting the severity of the
flu
is how we approach every other disease
early detection allows for early
treatment
and better outcomes seems like a pretty
common sense approach to me
yet this is not how we've attacked kovid
instead
we've impoverished millions by shutting
down economies
poured billions of dollars into
ventilator production and new drug and
vaccine development
but spent virtually nothing on research
and trials
using existing drugs and nutraceuticals
in fact there's been a concerted effort
to block doctors who actually treat
covet patients
from compassionately using their
off-label prescription rights
for early treatment protocols why
in his reflections on progress peaceful
coexistence and
intellectual freedom russian dissident
andrei sakharov wrote quote
the second basic thesis is that
intellectual freedom is essential to
human society
freedom to obtain and distribute
information
freedom for open-minded and unfearing
debate
and freedom from pressure by officialdom
and prejudices
such a trinity of freedom of thought is
the only guarantee against an
infection of people by mass myths
which in the hands of treacherous
hypocrites and demagogues can be
transformed into bloody dictatorship
freedom of thought is the only guarantee
of the feasibility of a scientific
democratic approach to politics
economics
and culture and to die in today's biased
news media
and social media within academic
journals
on college campuses in government
agencies and ivory towers
we are losing the freedom to obtain and
distribute information
the reaction to our first hearing on
early treatment is but one example
although not surprising in today's hyper
partisan climate
it is still shocking in that hearing we
heard from dr mcculloch
a cardiologist and vice chair of
medicine at baylor university medical
center
dr harvey rich senior professor of
epidemiology at yale university
and dr george fareed trained at harvard
university in the national
institutes of health combined
these doctors have more than 900
scientific research publications
extensive drug development experience
more than 80 years
clinical practice including treating
more than 1 000
high high-risk covet patients along with
thousands of other
lower risk coveted patients i was hoping
that
post-election by asking such eminently
qualified doctors to testify
about the rationale for and growing
effectiveness of early treatment
minds could be opened and lies could be
saved
unfortunately the democrat witness dr
ashish jah
began tweeting his negative viewpoint of
early treatment before the hearing even
began
and continues his media blitz for days
afterward
most obnoxiously and it was obnoxious
he penned an op-ed that the new york
times ran and headlined quote
the snake oil salesman of the senate
unquote
the absurdity of calling dr ja as a
witness or paying any attention
to him in the media was demonstrated
when i asked him during the hearing
have you treated any coveted patients
his reply
i have not sir dr mccullough
also talked about the circle of empathy
and medicine those who actually treat
covet patients are in the center
not only have they shown extraordinary
courage
exposing themselves to the disease they
also have the greatest empathy for
patients who experience the
fear and loneliness of a cova diagnosis
these are the medical practitioners the
heroes
that experts in the ivory towers and
media have chosen to ignore
and vilify the experts far
outside the circle of empathy have
developed and supported the current nih
guideline
of providing no treatment at all until
patients are sick enough to require
hospitalizations
as we are all aware at that point
treatment is
often too late so here we are again
holding a second hearing to obtain and
distribute information
on what is known about early treatment
of kovid
what could possibly be controversial
about that
some are calling this hearing dangerous
instead of waiting until
after the hearing to trash this
information and our witnesses
the new york times and other
publications have already run preemptive
attacks
implying implying this hearing is
anti-vaccine
so let me be clear this hearing like the
first hearing is focused on
early treatment of covid it is not about
vaccines
end of story in my opinion
discouraging and in some cases
prohibiting the research and use of
drugs that have been safely used for
decades has cost
tens if not hundreds of thousands of
people their lives
by the time any vaccine is fully
deployed no matter how successful how
effective how safe
millions more will become infected with
effective early treatment
fewer people will get seriously ill and
fewer people will die
so why not give early treatment a shot
what have we got to lose
and finally why is there such a
converted concerted effort
to silence the voices of courageous
health professionals
promoting early treatment it makes
no sense
let me make just a final point at the
beginning this end
epidemic when i first heard about the
potential of hydroxychloroquine
it intrigued me because to me a drug
like that
that's been around for 65 years shown to
be safe
it's cheap billions of tablets are
produced
every year we could have ramped up
production
if if that could be proven to be
effective
wouldn't that be the dream solution
why didn't we pursue that in ivor
mechtin
and family peer review why didn't why
didn't we look at
these drugs who are already there
generic
cheap mass producible
again it makes no sense without turning
over to
senator peters
thank you mr chairman uh you know our
nation continues
to battle a worsening public health and
economic crisis that has taken the lives
of nearly
284 000 americans
over 2200 americans are dying every day
from this
deadly virus and thanks to the tireless
work of our public health agencies the
private sector
and our scientific and medical
communities we've made progress
in treating this disease the food and
drug administration continues to use
scientific standards to authorize
innovative
and effective early treatments
unfortunately today's discussion
will not meet those same standards mr
chairman i certainly share your goal of
ensuring
patients across the country have access
to early
and effective treatments for coronavirus
but those statements must be based on
evidence and not
on politics the american people are
looking to congress for
accurate information for leadership
and for relief last month this committee
held a hearing that was billed as a
review of early outpatient treatments
for coronavirus
unfortunately that hearing amplified
unverified theories about treatments
that are not supported
by the scientific community instead of
hearing from expert witnesses about
scientific developments in the
coronavirus treatments
or how we can improve the pandemic
response
the committee was used as a platform to
attack science
and promote discredited treatments
the minority witness an expert in his
field
was subjected to personal attacks from
other witnesses
and from this diocese after testifying
he faced an online harassment campaign
unlike anything he had ever experienced
in any prior
congressional testimony this behavior
damages the credibility of this
committee
and does nothing to advance the health
and the safety
of the american people sadly it appears
that today's hearing is going to follow
the same path
playing politics with public health and
will not give us the information that we
need to take on this crisis
the minority was not consulted about the
scope of this hearing before
it was noticed the panelists have been
selected for their political
uh not their medical views and for that
reason the composition of the panel
creates a false and
terribly harmful impression of the
scientific and medical consensus
the witnesses have made many harmful
inflammatory statements
those statements include undermining a
covet 19 vaccine
promoting unproven therapeutics
discouraging common sense measures to
stop the spread of the virus like social
distancing and mask
and even comparing physicians who
support these interventions
to supporters of a nazi regime
now i certainly welcome diverse
perspectives but we have a
responsibility
to follow science to follow facts
not conspiracy theories and not
disinformation
to that end i'd like to enter mr
chairman into the record this statement
from 50 public health experts about the
importance of science
in our pandemic response i'd also like
to enter into the record
an op-ed written by dr ja the minority
witness prior
in the prior hearing regarding his
experience before this committee
and finally i'd like to enter statements
from four public health and scientific
organizations that discuss
scientific integrity and the needs of
our communities
during this pandemic without objection
that could be entered into the record mr
chairman
without objection mr chairman senate
hearings like
medical treatments should be based on
evidence
this hearing like the hearing before it
and the hearing before that
is unfortunately not i very much regret
that in this time of need americans
cannot turn to this committee for some
sound
guidance mr chairman we we can still
turn the tide of this pandemic
we can work together to ensure that
scientists have the resources that they
need to
conduct research and federal agencies
have the resources they need
to support and evaluate these efforts
we should be working to ensure that
doctors nurses and first responders have
personal
protective equipment that they need to
care for patients
in a safe manner we should be passing
bipartisan legislation that provides
desperately needed financial
relief to families states and small
businesses
and in the coming weeks we expect that
the first coronavirus vaccines will
become
available we should be conducting strong
oversight
including hearing testimony from
government officials responsible for
vaccine development and distribution
the commerce committee will be holding a
subcommittee on how we'll ensure
every american can get a vaccine
later this week we'll be discussing that
and i look forward to participating in a
robust discussion with both scientific
and logistics experts
we owe it to the american people to get
this right
and sadly today's hearing will not
provide accurate scientific information
or advance any useful efforts to slow
the spread
of the coronavirus pandemic thank you mr
chairman
well thank you senator peters i hope
anybody who
listened to that opening statement
anybody who's read the
the articles prior to this uh hearing
we'll actually go back and take a look
at the video that we
edited of our previous hearing then i
hope they actually listen to the
witnesses
and to their testimony into the
questions and answers
and just really understand how far from
reality the ranking member's opening
statement truly was
now it is the tradition this committee
is swearing witnesses so
those of you in webex if you'll just
raise your right hand two witnesses here
if you'll stand and raise your right
hand
do you swear the testimony you get
before this committee will be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth so help you god thank you
our first witness is dr rameen
at best i get him 50 percent right dr
oscui
is a native washingtonian he's a
graduate of georgetown university
college of arts and sciences and
columbia university college of
physicians and surgeons
he trained at georgetown university
hospital in internal medicine and
cardiovascular disease
at washington hospital center he is
board certified internal medicine and
cardiovascular diseases
he is ceo of fox fox hall cardiology in
washington dc
he's a past president of medical staff
at sibley memorial hospital
and was physician of the year for 2015
for sibley memorial hospital johns
hopkins
since 1996 his peers have continuously
voted him
as one of washingtonians magazine's top
doctors in cardiology
he has treated several dozen covered 19
patient patients and is published in the
area and since i
announced your uh presence at this
hearing i've heard from all kinds of
patients what a fabulous doctor you are
you're very kind thank you for coming
here thanks for being a doctor dr
oscar it's my honor i'm going to just
read from my brief personal statement
i've been making make sure your
microphone's on and that the
microphone is close to your your mouse
so we can hear
uh i don't see red light on it but it
looks like it's green
okay my name is dr remin oscar i'm a
board certified cardiologist and
internist
who practice who is licensed to practice
in dc maryland and virginia
and as the senator correctly stated i've
treated several dozen
code patients since the outbreak of the
pandemic my remarks are directed in part
to the differing roles and
responsibilities
of scientific researchers and government
agencies and practicing physicians in
the health care crisis
whenever there's a health crisis whether
it's a worldwide pandemic
or family member hit with stroke or
heart attack our nation's practicing
positions not only the critical first
responders
in many cases they are the only ones on
the line working with
and for the patient there are brilliant
practitioners of academic medicine
and nb phds many of them employed by our
most profitable drug companies who
develop seemingly
miraculous cures or therapies but it is
the front line
physicians who certainly with the help
of scientific researchers
and billion dollar drug pharmaceutical
companies must fight
and win the war against disease
particularly a disease or ailment
that is new and we don't have decades of
research to look back on
with patients who if we do nothing may
suffer and die needlessly
why then with a disease we had never
seen before in late march
are practicing physicians being
condemned ridiculed
or shamed in some cases for doing what
practicing physicians have always done
using their professional skills and
expertise to make the best
practical life-saving use of the
existing
scientific research it would be
wonderful if
last march the fda or the nih or a few
big drug companies could have announced
an
instant cure for a disease that had just
been discovered
or of course in that event we would have
all prescribed it
easy peasy but they didn't have it then
and they don't have it now that's one
reason why the fda encourages
the use of fda approved drugs approved
for one disease to be responsibly
and ethically used in the field for
other ailments not yet researched or
approved
in fact that is how many cures or
treatments get discovered
drugs or treatments invented and tested
for one disease or ailment
are applied in a novel way or for an
elementary disease
they have not yet been approved for or
tested with
the health policy establishment's
criticism of the frontline doctors
was over the top and it was unfounded
first for example drugs like
hydroxychloroquine ivermectin
which are fda approved for certain uses
have extensive safeguards
even for non-approved uses they were
both
and approved decades ago and have an
established
record of efficacy and a comprehensive
information on possible side effects
the physicians can review and are
legally and ethically required to review
before prescribing
secondly the fact is that no doctor
should be prescribing these drugs or in
fact any drug
without following standard protocols
observed for any drug
or any patient even if there is fda
approved scientific research proving
that hydroxycork and works for malaria
it's approved use
or lupus a long-standing alternative use
one must do a case history and consider
the individual patient
before prescribing it practicing
medicine may be an art as much as
science
but is certainly not quote paint by the
number
earlier this year uh we faced a new
dangerously infectious virus in such a
health crisis
like any other crisis with an unknown
and unproven enemy
cannot rely exclusively on the tried and
true but it was
worse than that affirmative steps to
keep physicians and patients
ignorant were taken indeed censorship of
scientific research
indeed medical mccarthyism became the
norm
it is not an insult against science to
conclude that action should be taken
in the midst of an emergency based on
the best facts available
nor any more than it is an insult
against history to use tactics or
strategy
in our national defense that have not
been peer reviewed
i believe that landing craft were rarely
used in full-scale amphibious invasion
before d-day
the ones we developed specifically for
that purpose obviously could not be
tested
in full battlefield conditions does that
mean we
could not go ahead with the normandy
invasion because we had no double
blind peer-reviewed studies for these
vehicles i think weather forecast that
day
was a bit sketchy too even outside
of an emergency it is no disrespect to
science to say some medical treatments
that some physicians deem prudent
for their patients should be allowed and
yes promoted
even if those have not been the subject
someone's peer-reviewed phd thesis
or years of regulatory process very few
of us
will become drug company executives top
medical researchers
or high-ranking health bureaucrats but
it is almost guaranteed that each of us
is quite likely
sometime somewhere to be a patient under
the care of a trusted physician
who will hopefully have the help not the
hindrance of the research establishment
thank you senator thank you dr oscar our
next witness
is via webex dr jean-jacques writer
dr reiter is a broward health medical
center physician who specializes in
pulmonary medicine
internal medicine and critical care he
previously served as the chief medical
information officer
for broward health and as an assistant
professor at drexel university college
of medicine dr reiter
serves as a speaker for glaxosmithkline
astrazeneca
and forest laboratories as well as
serves on advisory boards for pfizer his
publications most recently include
a study titled quote use of ivermectin
is associated with lower mortality and
hospitalized patients with coronavirus
disease
2019. unquote dr reiter received his md
from the drexel university college of
medicine
and has accumulated over 22 years of
experience in his field
dr reiter thank you very much honorable
chairman and senators
of the committee on homeland security my
name is dr georgia kreider
i'm unfortunately unable to attend these
hearings in person
as i'm currently taking care of over 35
hospitalized patients
and it's an honor and privilege to stand
here in front of the committee providing
first-hand
experience on the early treatment for
covet 19.
my team has gained extensive experience
with the treatment of cover 19
in both inpatients and our patients
during this pandemic
back in april we were faced with a
rapidly deteriorating patient population
with no effective treatment
extraordinary times called for
extraordinary measures
i could not stand idly by as i've seen
more people die
in these last six months that i've seen
in my entire medical career combined
based on in vitro data by dr wagstaff my
team was able to develop and implement
an ivermectin-based protocol
that showed tremendous success in
treating covet 19. this laid the
foundation for the peer-reviewed icon
study which was published in chest a
major u.s
based medical journal the overall
mortality in that study decreased from
25 percent in the conventional care
group
to 15 in the ivermectin treatment group
in patients with severe pulmonary
disease at onset
the mortality decreased from 81 to 39
during the second wave of the pandemic
it was common for my team to treat in
excess of 40 patients with covet 19 on a
daily
basis this icon protocol has been
optimized since
and we have learned a lot from our
successes and failures
the success rate of the ivermectin-based
protocol is now far superior to what it
was in its early days
hydromectin-based protocols have now
been studied across the world
yet no major large-scale double-blind
randomized controlled study
has just been published in a peer review
journal i will defer
more review of the literature to dr
corey who is going to be testifying
later
recent in vitro studies confirmed our
clinical experience
that the dosing regimen of ivermectin
200 micrograms per kilogram on two
consecutive days was clinically
effective
of the hundreds of outpatient treated by
my team
only two i repeat two were admitted to
the hospital
one due to heart failure the other one
due to symptomatic delay of over a week
before seeking medical attention neither
one of them
died neither one of them needed
intubation
both of them have now been discharged to
home without complications
ivermectin is a widely used medication
with excess of 3.7 billion doses
administered worldwide
it is currently part of the world health
organization
model list of essential medications the
icon
dosing regimen is based on currently
accepted dosing regimen
for norwegian scabies the dosing regimen
has long-standing safety data safety of
a medication
is due to its pharmac pharmacokinetics
and possible interactions
but not on its intended use
as is the case with any infection early
intervention
has been proven time over again
that is of critical importance the same
is due for
it's the same is true for covet 19.
early intervention
increases the likelihood of keeping
people out of the hospital
and hence decreasing the pressure on the
health care system
early intervention is cost effective as
it decreases the overall health care
expenditure
early intervention decreases viral
shedding and vile transmission in the
home
setting which is currently believed to
be a major site of transmission
early intervention increases survival
early intervention
decreases the economic impact
notwithstanding
impending vaccination programs vaccines
are not 100
effective and may not be widely
available for many months
many patients may be unable to take the
vaccines for healthcare reasons or up
not to do so
long-term immunity of these vaccines has
not yet been documented
based on these factors treatment for
corvette 19 will need to remain
on the forefront even after vaccination
programs are initiated
ivermectin is effective in early disease
latest exposed exposure prophylaxis and
pre-exposure prophylaxis
ivermectin is an oral medication
requiring no monitoring
ivermectin is safe ivermectin is
inexpensive and widely available
the us has spent billions of dollars on
a multitude of treatment options
my team is ready to proceed with the
randomized control
trials to address any residual doubt
relating to ivermectin use
yet were unable to do so due to lack of
funding and support
a few hundred thousand dollars may
definitely prove or disprove the
effectiveness of ivermectin for early
treatment
with a properly designed and implemented
randomized control trial
funding a little bit more funding could
look at the effectiveness of pre and
post exposure prophylaxis using
avermectin
a couple million dollars could complete
a multi-center double-blind
inpatient placebo-controlled trial
forever mechanism
ladies and gentlemen i implore you as a
front-line provider of covet-19 to do
better
to provide us the answers we need as
healthcare providers
to help your constituents survive this
horrible pandemic in great numbers
after personally witnessing the results
of ivamectin-based protocols
i cannot stand by and allow hundreds of
thousands of people
to go untreated thank you thank you dr
ryder
our next witness is here in person dr
pierre corey
dr corey is the former associate
professor and chief of the critical care
service and medical director of the
trauma and life support center at the
university of wisconsin
and recently joined the icu service at
aurora st luke medical center
in milwaukee he is board certified in
critical medicine
pulmonary diseases and internal medicine
dr corey has traveled across multiple
states in the u.s to care for coven 19
patients throughout the pandemic
he is also the president of the front
line cobit 19 critical care alliance
a non-profit organization critical care
specialist
led by professor paul merrick whose
mission over the last nine months is
focused on the research and development
of effective treatment protocols for
cova 19
using repurposed drugs he received his
md from st
george's university school of medicine
and i'll only add that
we added dr corey very late to our i
think our hearing in may
because i'd heard of his development of
i guess anti-inflammatory steroids in
critical care on covid and dr corey i
have to tell you i've had doctors come
up to me and thank me
for holding that hearing where they
listen to you change their thinking
they believe they've saved their
patients lives because of your testimony
at that hearing i hope your testimony
will be as impactful today
dr corey senator thank you and and
thank you for uh holding this hearing
i just want to start out i didn't think
i'd have to say this but i want to
register my offense
at the ranking member's opening
statement i was discredited as a
politician
i am a physician and a man of science
i've done nothing
nothing but commit myself to scientific
truth and the care of patients
and and to hear that i'm here because of
a political angle i am not a politician
i'm a physician
i want to start out by saying that
i'm not speaking as an individual i'm
speaking on behalf
of the organization that i'm a part of
we are a group
of some of the most highly published
physicians in the world
we have near 2 000 peer-reviewed
publications among us
led by dr professor paul marrick who's
our intellectual leader
we came together early on in the
pandemic and all we have sought is to
review the world's literature on
every facet of this disease trying to
develop effective protocols
you just mentioned that i was here in
may
and i touted i wouldn't say i
recommended
that it was critical that we use
corticosteroids in this disease
when all of the national and
international healthcare organizations
said we cannot use those that turned out
to be a life-saving recommendation
i am here again today with a new
recommendation
in the last nine months in our review of
all of the literature as a group
again we are some of the most highly
published physicians
in our specialty and the world
we have done nothing but try to figure
out
how to identify a repurposed and
available drug
to treat this illness we have
now come to the conclusion after nine
months
and i have to point out i am severely
troubled by the fact that the nih the
fda and the cdc i do not know of any
task force
that was assigned or compiled to review
repurposed drugs
in an attempt to treat this disease
everything has been about
novel and or expensive pharmaceutically
engineered drugs
things like tosalyzumab and rendezvous
and monoclonal antibodies and vaccines
we have hundred years of medicine
development we know
we are expert in all the medicines we
use and i do not know of a task force
that has been focused on repurposed
drugs i will tell you
that my group and our organization i
will say
that we have filled that void we that is
all we have done is focus on the things
we know
and things we do and i'm here to tell
you dr
reiter he just presented it was one
he has one study of the many that i want
to talk about
and i want to talk about that we have a
solution to this crisis
there is a drug that is proving to be of
miraculous impact and when i say miracle
i do not use that term lightly
and i don't want to be sensationalized
when i say that that is a scientific
recommendation
based on mountains of data that has
emerged in the last three months
when i am told and i just had to hear
this in the opening sentence
that we are touting things that are not
fda or nih recommended let me be clear
the nih their recommendation on
ivermectin which is to not use it
outside of controlled trials
is from august 27th we are now in
december
this is three to four months later
mountains of data have emerged from all
from many centers and countries around
the world showing the miraculous
effectiveness of ivermectin it basically
obliterates transmission of this virus
if you take it
you will not get sick i want to briefly
summarize
the data my manuscript again published
by some
of the the the most con we have
contributed more to the medical
knowledge of our specialty
in our careers than anyone else can
claim as a group
and our manuscript which was posted on
medicine preprint server
details all of this evidence i want to
briefly summarize it number one
we have evidence that ivermectin is
effective not only
in prophylaxis in the prevention if you
take it you will not get sick
we just came across a trial last night
from argentina by the lead investigator
of ivan benton in argentina
dr hector carvalho they prophylaxis 800
healthcare workers
not one got sick in the 400 that they
didn't prophylaxis ivermectin
58 that's like 237 of those 400 got sick
if you take it you will not get sick it
has immense and potent antiviral
activity
we know that from the first study in
monash it has made the bench to the
bedside
prophylaxis we now have four
large randomized control trials totaling
over
1500 patients each trial showing
that as a prophylaxis agent it is
immensely effective you will not get
sick you will be protected
from getting ill if you take it in early
outpatient treatment
we have three randomized control trials
and multiple observation as well as case
series
showing that if you take ivermectin the
need for hospitalization
and death will decrease the most
profound evidence we have is in the
hospitalized patients
we have four randomized control trials
there multiple observation trials all
showing the same thing
you will not die or you will die at much
much much lower rates
statistically significant large
magnitude results if you take
ivermectin it is proving to be a wonder
drug
it has already won the nobel prize in
medicine in 2015 for its impacts on
global health
in the eradication of parasitic diseases
it is proving to be
an immensely powerful anti-viral and
anti-inflammatory agent it is
critical for its use in this disease we
again stand by our manuscript it is a
scientific major it's been submitted for
peer review
but please recognize peer review takes
time
it takes months we do not have months we
have a hundred thousand patients in the
hospital right now dying
i'm a lung specialist i'm an isu
specialist i've cared for more dying
covert patients than anyone can imagine
they're dying because they can't breathe
they can't breathe
they're on high flow oxygen delivery
devices they're on non-invasive
ventilators
and or they're sedated and paralyzed and
attached to mechanical ventilators that
breathe for them
and i watch them every day they die by
the time they get me
in the icu they're already dying they're
almost impossible to recover
early treatment is key we need to
offload the hospitals
we are tired i can't keep doing this
if you look at my manuscript and if i
have to go back to work next week
any further deaths are going to be
needless deaths and i cannot be
traumatized by that
i cannot keep caring for patients when i
know that they could have been saved
with earlier treatment and that drug
that will treat them and prevent the
hospitalization is ivermectin
this is i am here today i'm calling to
action
the nih their last recommendation was
august 27th
august 27th i want to be clear
i am not here as a politician or a
dramatist or sensationalizing
what i'm recommending i'm going to be
very clear and very simple
all i ask is for the nih
to review our data that we've compiled
of all of the emerging data we have
almost 30 studies everyone is reliably
and reproducibly
positive showing the dramatic impacts of
ivermectin
please i'm just asking that they review
our manuscript it is a serious
manuscript
by serious highly experienced physicians
and researchers we we have
i cannot call on more credibility than
we have we're not just a
a random doctor who's saying that we
have a cure i don't want to say i have a
cure i'm just asking review our data
we have immense amounts of data to show
that ivermectin must be
implemented and implemented now senator
the last thing i want to say
is you know who's dying here
it's it's our african-american and
latino and elderly it's some of the most
disadvantaged
and impoverished members of our society
they are dying at higher rates than
anyone else
it's the most it's it's the most severe
discrepancy i've seen in my medical
career
and we are responsible to protect those
disadvantaged members
we have a special duty to provide
counter measures
the amount of evidence to show that
ivermectin
is life-saving and protective is so
immense
and the drug is so safe my colleagues
have talked about it
it must be instituted implemented i am
asking the nih to review our data and
come up with recommendations for society
thank you okay well thank dr corey and i
will i will
make you this guarantee that uh before
the day is out we'll have a letter
first of all we'll enter all your data
into our hearing record and then i'll
have a letter to the ni
nih asking them to review it please and
hopefully i'll have some
sanders join me in that our next witness
is dr
armand balboni dr balboni is the chief
executive officer for
apoli therapeutics his career has
included medical research and drug
development experience in civilian
academic and military organizations he's
a partner and a member of the board of
directors of bloom burton and company
where he is the firm senior advisor for
regulatory medical affairs
as an active duty military officer dr
balboni served as a staff officer in the
u.s army research institute
of infectious infectious diseases he
completed a military staff fellowship
with the u.s food and drug
administration
and wanted to serve as the deputy
director of clinical and regulatory
affairs for the us army
dr bell boney has held multiple academic
positions at westfield state university
the university of maryland university
college and the united states military
academy at west point
dr balboni completed his doctoral work
in the md phd program
at the icon school of medicine at mount
sinai and earned his law degree at
brooklyn law school
dr balboni so
thank you mr chairman uh ranking member
of peters and the entire committee for
for for your leadership and the
opportunity to speak today about the
need for early treatment
dr if you could talk a little bit louder
before you boost his
sure is that any better yes it is thanks
all right great so uh again thank you
for this opportunity to uh to speak
as as you've noted um i've worked in the
infectious disease
front lines in many roles i'm a simple
drug development
uh physician and scientist um and and i
say that uh with all
with all humility um as a military
fellow at the fda during the ebola
crisis
uh we looked at some of these drugs uh
broad spectrum antivirals to include
things like fabirapure and rendezvir
we are no further along now than we were
then with getting those drugs approved
because of the very fragmented nature
of what we do as our approach to
treating
these kinds of illnesses um i have to
say uh
uh i never thought i would have to say
this um but i am a lifelong democrat
with a subscription to the new york
times and i have to say i was quite
dismayed this morning and almost didn't
participate
when i saw the news um that i was
participating as a fringe member
of an anti-vaxxer group that is that
couldn't be further from the truth
um i read further down um in the new
york times and saw that 202
000 new cases uh were presented uh
yesterday in the u.s
and i'm and i'm confronted with with the
motto that uh accompanied me
in over 17 years as a physician and
scientist in the us army
one team one fight and mission first um
we've got to get this right i remain
deeply concerned with our long-term
viability to combat
not only cobit 19 but other pandemics
that inevitably will happen
we have to take a whole government
approach um the last 11 months have
shown us what we can do when we do that
um it's redefined what's possible for
vaccine development we may be on the
precipice of new
technologies that that will absolutely
inform how we
develop vaccines in the future but we
are not done
um many are ready to say that we did it
with vaccines
and some effective treatments that that
have been noted to be quite expensive
and useful
in limited situations but we're failing
to adequately build a continuum of
solutions data-driven solutions
for copic 19 and the inevitable future
pandemics
we need options now at every stage
and in scalable and readily
implementable ways as the crisis worsens
we need um oral broad spectrum
therapeutics to be able to treat
patients in the outpatient setting
we can't treat them adequately and we
can't continue to send newly infected
patients home
with this potential hope of an iv
infusion
um and say put on a mask and wait for
the vaccine
uh we we can't live with the outcomes
there i might i tip my hats my
colleagues
at infusion clinics and and uh those
setting up
uh clinics in tents and parking lots but
the drugs are too expensive not
available and unlikely to help
that the hundreds of thousands of
patients that are that are coming out of
this
the vast majority of americans just to
be clear that
who test positive we tell them to self
quarantine
employ watchful waiting and then go to
the hospital if they have beds
if their system if their symptoms worsen
this protocol
confirms that we have a gap in our
treatment landscape we need
an oral stars kobe 2 specific treatment
right now
that that helps to treat those with
confirmed infections
and one that's practicable scalable and
can bring a plug and play
type of approach to our health care
system as as this committee addressed
and and my colleagues that are witnesses
here have also addressed
um we have to include vaccines and best
medical practices nobody is denying that
nobody here is an anti-vaxxer um uh and
and i
again i have to say take great offense
to that to that statement as a scientist
and physician um oral antivirals um
targeting stars club e2 offer a strong
solution um
we we have the potential to play an
important role
in the hands of physicians treating
their clovid 19 patients outside of the
hospital
again these drugs are not intended to
replace covid19 vaccines
and many promising oral antivirals are
most effective when used early
most will never have access most
patients will ever have access to them
as we attempt to bring all the risk out
of
our large randomized control trials to
fully read out we as a
as a group are running two large phase
three trials in the u.s
under ind in a phase two post-exposure
prophylaxis trial and long-term care
we are doing that work and i do not
suggest that we abandon our gold
standard rcts
however to singularly rely on rcts in
the middle of a pandemic
is just not common sense we need to
develop
um hybrid trial methodologies by
combining the best parts of rcts
and observational studies to produce
real world data right now
that can together with our rcts uh
present real world evidence about how
these things can be used it's our best
chance to save lives now and during
future outbreaks
if we fail to change our approach we're
going to be talking about this the next
time there's an outbreak it's going to
happen
it's unfortunate but we've got to
utilize
this pandemic to bring solutions to
these patients right now
thank you mr chairman thank you
committee for your consideration
thank you dr balboni our next witness is
dr jane orient
dr ourian has served as the executive
director of the association of american
physicians and surgeons
aaps since 1989 and is currently
president of doctors for disaster
preparedness
more than 200 of her papers and op-ed
pieces have been published in the
scientific and popular literature on a
variety of subjects
including risk assessment natural and
technological hazards and non-hazards
and medical economics and ethics she's
the editor of aaps
news the doctors for disaster
preparedness newsletter
civil defense perspectives and is the
managing editor of the journal of
american physicians and surgeons
dr orient obtained her undergraduate
degrees in chemistry
in mathematics from the university of
arizona in tucson and her md from
columbia university
college of physicians and surgeons in
1974. dr orient is
formally clinically his formerly
clinical faculty
in the department of internal medicine
at the university of arizona college of
medicine has been in solo private
practice
of general internal medicine since 1981
dr orient
thank you chairman johnson and ranking
mender member peters
and committee members for allowing me to
present the plea of practicing
physicians for early
and prophylactic home treatment for
coven 19
and also thanks to the witnesses for the
opportunity to learn from you
we urge the committee to exercise your
oversight functions over federal
agencies that are
effectively blocking treatment that
could prevent
a hundred thousand needless deaths and
stop the crippling fear
and the destruction of millions of
livelihoods
on august 18th ron johns senator ron
johnson senator mike lee
and senator ted cruz asked the fda
to provide any studies and data that
informed the fda's apparent
determination
that giving hydroxychloroquine to
infected
outpatients within seven days from the
onset of symptoms
will have no clinical effect and may be
harmful to the patient
fda's tardy response provided no
references
pertaining to the question the only
logical conclusion is
that the fda's extremely influential
determination
that prevented treatment for untold
thousands of patients was without
foundation
fda commissioner stephen hahn has stated
correctly
that fda has no authority to regulate
the practice of medicine
and the doctors have the right to
prescribe approved drugs for off-label
uses
but as aaps has shown in its lawsuit
against the fda
state agencies have used the fda's
language as the basis of regulations to
block
or forbid the prescribing or dispensing
of hydroxychloroquine
in march hhs secretary azar asked
barda for a nationwide expanded access
investment
investigational new drug protocol for
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine in
the national
strategic stockpile but ins this would
have legitimized these drugs
for the treatment of cova 19 outside a
hospital
but instead influential physicians or
officials
non-physicians transformed the request
into an emergency use authorization
only for hospitalized patients to the
patients who were the least
likely to benefit so instead of
expanding excess
the eua restricted access and later fda
withdrew the eua
further impeding its use and the hhs
is presumably still hoarding more than
50 million doses
of hydroxychloroquine while people are
complaining about a potential shortage
at its november meeting the ama refused
to rescind
its unprecedented statement calling for
possessions to stop
prescribing hydroxychloroquine until
sufficient evidence becomes available
to conclusively illustrate that benefit
outweighs harm
yet there have been 192 studies
compiled on hydroxychloroquine with all
showing some benefit when used early
in contrast to the handful of studies on
rem de severe
or monoclonal antibodies which are the
only things that the nih recommends
more than 65 years of experience and
hundreds of millions of patients have
demonstrated safety
hydroxychloroquine is safer than most
over-the-counter drugs
including acetaminophen
however organized medicine and academic
physicians such as dr ashes jaw
have stated that the evidence is
insufficiently scientific
doesn't meet their gold standards of the
randomized controlled trial
but the fact is that most of the
guidelines that we use
for most diseases have um
relied on lower orders of evidence
necessarily
and studies with appropriately analyzed
data give results identical to
rcts and rcts themselves are not
infallible because they can be designed
to succeed
or designed to fail researchers in two
hydroxychloroquine trials even used
toxic or lethal doses of the drug and
then
noticed that yeah it did harm
publications in the most prestigious
journals does not assure
reliability there were huge studies that
were based on
probably fabricated data
with flaws that were undetected by the
peer reviewers or the editors
a russian publication and had to be
retracted by lancet
and the new england journal of medicine
but not quickly enough to prevent their
significant
misleading and harmful effects rcts are
useful for testing
but they're not for making discoveries
which are often serendipitous like the
use of iron mechan for example
in patients nursing home patients with
scabies the smallpox vaccine was
discovered because gps were sharing
observations now we call them
anecdotes at the pub they noticed that
farmers who had had cow pox didn't seem
to get smallpox
or they may result from the study of
basic science and observation on
patients
like today's protocol for granulomatosis
was based on a 1973
article of non-randomized patients
which was written none by none other
than dr anthony fauci
today we have top-down authority-based
standard of care
for early covet promulgated by nih
guidelines
it which is therapeutic nihilism we've
lately added the
expensive largely unavailable monoclonal
antibodies but other than that
before the patient's in the hospital and
on oxygen the nih recommends
nothing this is shocking and
unprecedented
but in today's litigious environment
doctors who follow this standard of care
are protected
and those who dare prescribe outside of
it could be
fired removed from their insurance
panels investigated and even de-licensed
patients nationwide are calling us at
aaps
searching for a doctor who will treat
them one patient told me he had had his
wife drive him all the way to dallas
when all the doctors he knew in tucson
refused to prescribe for him
and his symptoms got better within hours
of getting
hydroxychloroquine from the doctor in
dallas
doctors are reporting to us that they
can't get hydroxychloroquine for their
nursing home patients
and the family doctors of the heml
doctors even told us that infectious
disease specialists
have refused to treat covent patients
we're relying on quarantines masks and
lockdowns
these are not backed by rcts they have
not stopped the pandemic
they're not sustainable vaccines are
touted as the great hope but we don't
have them yet
and they have not yet been shown to
prevent contagion what we need now
is effective early treatment for coven
19
hydroxychloroquine and other safe
long-used agents
such as ivermectin is showing particular
promise but there are others
they could be immediately available if
the government stopped blocking access
and deterring their use physicians need
to do as they've always done
they need to respond to the needs of
their patients
use the best available information share
that information and continuously strive
to do better
thank you so much for this opportunity
thank you dr ourian our our final
witness is dr
jay bhattacharya dr bartochari is
professor of medicine at stanford
university and a research associate at
the national bureau of economics
research
dr bhattacharya's research focuses on
the health and well-being of vulnerable
populations with a particular emphasis
on the role role of government programs
biomedical innovation
and economics dr bhattacharya's recent
research focuses on the epidemiology of
covert 19
as well as an evaluation of policy
responses to the epidemic
dr botticerio was the senior author of
the first studies
of the cereal prevalence of covert 19 in
los angeles county and santa clara
county
as well as the major league baseball
cerro prevalence
study he is the co-author of the great
barrington
declaration which urges an end to
lockdowns in the
adoption of a focused protection
strategy to address the coven 19
epidemic he has published 135 articles
in
top peer-reviewed scientifical journals
in medicine economics
health policy epidemiology statistics
law
and public health among other fields he
holds an md and a phd in economics
both earned at stanford university dr
bhattacharya thank you senator uh thank
you for the opportunity to testify
uh i feel a little bit out of place
because i'm going to be talking about uh
about
how well we've done or what how
dangerous the epidemic
is as far as uh patients are concerned
uh i'll
cite some statistics on that and i'll
talk about the policy response but i
will also
return to the theme of the of the of the
uh
of this hearing which is on um on the
incentives to evaluate
uh therapies especially therapies that
don't have
uh a uh financial interest behind them
uh so let me first start by with some
comments on how dangerous cover 19 is at
an individual level
early in the epidemic the world health
organization publicized a very
misleading 3.4 percent case fatality
rate that panicked the world
the number's misleading because for the
typical person infected the usual
outcome spans the range from no symptoms
whatsoever
to a mild cold to the severe vile
pneumonia that the media highlights that
we've heard about in this in this
hearing
uh thus many infections are not
identified as cases at least especially
in the early days because they didn't
come to the attention of doctors or
public health authorities we know from a
series of studies specific
specific sars code two antibodies in the
blood which provide evidence of prior
covet infections this is true
and from these studies we can estimate
the true covit infection survival rate
uh because of a recent publication of
the bolton of world health organization
surveying 61 of these studies worldwide
we now have a good estimate of the
infection survival rate
it turns out to vary by orders of
magnitude by age that's this which is
the single most important risk factor
although there are others
for people 70 and over the infection
survival rate is 95
it's a deadly disease especially for
older people
uh for people under 70 though the
infection survival rate is 99.95 percent
let me say that number again 99.95 and
with improvements in treatment and
patient management like
dexamethasone as we've heard about and
also improved ventilator protocols
these numbers are improving all the time
and they could be better
at the same time the harms of the
lockdown are manifold and devastating
including plummeting childhood
vaccination rates worse cardiovascular
disease outcomes
less cancer screening deteriorating
mental health today just a few
strolls already high and it will get get
worse in coming years as more people
come in with late stage cancer
worsening diabetes and advanced heart
disease that should have been identified
and treated this year
the social isolation induced by lockdown
has led to a sharp rise in opioid and
drug related overdoses
similar to the deaths of despair that
occurred in the wake of the 2008
great recession social isolation the
elderly contributed sharp rise in
dementia related deaths around the
country
for children the cessation of in person
schooling since the spring
has led to catastrophic learning losses
with severe projected adverse
consequences for effective students
lifespans
according to a cdc estimate one in four
adults seriously considered suicide this
past june
one in four among 25 to 44 year olds the
cdc reported a 26
increase in excess all-cause mortality
relative to past years
even though fewer than five percent of
the 2020 deaths in this age group has
been due to
cover 19. the two main planks of the
great britain declaration and the focus
protection ideas follow logically from
these facts
for older people covert 19 is a deadly
disease that should be met with
overwhelming resources aimed at
protecting them wherever they are
whether in nursing homes in their home
their workplace or multi-generational
homes they should be prioritized for
vaccines
and we should be actively seeking widely
available and effective treatments
referred in this committee
uh for the non-vulnerable those who face
a far
greater harm from the lockdowns than
they do from covert 19 infection risk
the lockdown should be lifted and for
those who sowed aside normal life
resumed
but what about better treatments for
coverage 19 patients i said earlier
we've made a lot of progress in learning
how to manage and treat the disease over
the past months
but i think it is has been a lot less
than it should have been
strikingly the most useful advance in
treatment involves repurposing a drug
that is already in widespread use of
entirely off patent
the steroid dexamethasone which is
effective in helping severely ill cover
patients avoid a deadly and detrimental
immune response
as a professor of medicine my inbox is
filled with scientists and physicians
who have ideas for similarly repurposing
existing drugs
vitamins minerals and other therapies
for early treatment of covering 19
infection
for many of these ideas there are good
patho physiological reasons and
observational evidence believe they
might work
however there's no randomized trials to
evaluate whether they work
doctors are free to use them off label
that is the fda approved them for use
for some past other indication
but they lack a gold standard evaluation
of the efficacy of outpatient management
so most doctors will not use them
so to me the question is before
dismissing these treatments is affected
because of lack of randomized evidence
i think the question we need to answer
is why have there been so
few randomized evaluations especially
large-scale ones
of these therapies and for that answer
i'm going to put on my economist hack
for drugs and therapies on patent a
patent holder has a strong interest in
running randomized evaluations
navigating the drug through the fda's
approval process
by contrast for drugs and therapies with
no patent holder no one has much
interest in funding expensive randomized
trials or working
residuals to moved the fda regulatory
process for rapid approval or even slow
approval
the bottleneck then is not the fda it's
the lack of a residual claimant for
these drugs and treatment
investigators working at academic
medical centers may have a reputational
interest in evaluating these drugs as
we've seen frontline
doctors have an incentive to find good
treatments for their patients
but they must find funds from somewhere
for them and pharmaceutical companies
typically have no interest in it
in principle the nih exists to solve
this market failure it could and should
use its resources to help fund
randomized evaluations these drugs for
off-label purposes
and it has funded some important drug
evaluation work uh such as the study to
determine the right dosage and
metabolism of drugs prescribed for
children on cobia 19.
it's also funded some trials uh for for
some uh for for drugs
for hospitalized patients for the most
part though they funded
trials for non-patent drugs the nih has
made comparatively little effort to
catalyze
randomized evaluations of off-patent
drugs from coven-19 therapeutics
by contrast the nih has devoted
considerable resources to aid the
covenant 19 vaccine randomized trial
studies
even the highest profile randomized
valuation dexamethasone was not
funded by the nih the nih's relative
lack of interest in the rapid randomized
evaluation of non-patented drug
represents the government failure that
has likely led to worse covert 19
outcomes than we would have had
otherwise thank you for the opportunity
to testify
thank you mr or dr bhattacharya
uh in a interesting display of uh
close-mindedness i
i don't believe we have any democrat
senators that really
are inquisitive enough to even ask any
questions of this distinguished panel
uh i appreciate the fact that the
senator and dr
paul is here so what i'll do is i'll
defer my questioning for
for dr paul thank you mr chairman
i'd like to begin by apologizing for the
juvenile diatribe
from the ranking member science is about
having an open mind
science is about disputation debate
evidence
and it's discussed and the contention
and the back and forth is how we
determine what the truth is but if you
close your mind completely to this and
are not willing to listen
i think that's how science dies that's
when we say well the government
consensus or the scientific consensus is
this
well that's that's the closing of the
scientific mind and that's a recipe for
a disaster
science is also not about ad hominem and
attacks
so by attacking this panel without
listening to it leaving in a huff
and having no questions shows a
small-mindedness a closed-mindedness
and really it should be everything that
we should avoid
i'm not here to be an advocate for one
treatment over the other and i will ask
some tough questions to the panel but
i'm open-minded enough
to listen to their side and see and try
to determine whether or not it's a good
treatment or bad
but to immediately close our mind i
think is a bad way of looking at this
i had a good friend die yesterday from
this so i'm not one who's saying this
isn't a deadly disease
um she lived a couple doors down and
we're sad
kelly and i are both sad about what
happened
about six months ago we had a friend who
died in their 30s
not from the disease but from lack of a
stress ekg she died from a terminal
arrhythmia
in her 30s with two young children but
her stress ekg was canceled because
the government decided that we shouldn't
do it it was an elective procedure
it was delayed and she died from a
terminal arrhythmia
so people do also die from the decisions
that
people make the most important thing is
is no one person is right the panelists
are not all right and people should
question them and go back and forth and
we try to figure out the truth from that
but it's a mistake to say that one
person should have all the power to
determine what we should do when we
place too much confidence in government
doctors
such as dr fauci dr corey mentioned that
he mentioned in june about steroids
i mentioned it in march when dr fauci
came into my committee
hearing my first thought about the
final pathway here with covid in the end
stages
is not too dissimilar from other final
pathways
adult respiratory distress syndrome i
had a friend who's a surgeon
who got the strep-eating flesh from
operating on somebody who had it
and a blood splatter he got it the
chance of losing your limbs is like 50
to 70 percent
it's like a 50 chance of losing all your
limbs it's a devastating disease but
one of the final common pathways like
covet is your blood vessels leak fluid
into your lungs
it's a sort of a toxic shock kind of
syndrome they treated him with high dose
steroids and so i raised my hand to dr
fausch and said do you think steroids
might have a role in this
and he sort of dismissed me and said
that the studies were showing that it
probably wouldn't work
but i would think most people would
argue now that one of the
most significant developments in the
acute care of the covid patient has been
the steroids actually
and trying to get them the steroids
before they've gotten into the the full
ards syndrome
um some are even getting it at a very
early stage in in the disease
but that came from people asking
questions being skeptical
and not letting one doctor such as dr
fauci say oh that's not right young man
go sit in the corner
we need to have an open mind i'm not
saying i'm always right i'm a bystander
and i'm not an expert
but i try to ask the important questions
one of the questions that i'd like to
ask
and i think this is the difficulty of
proving the situation on
either ivermectin or hydro hydroxychlor
hydroxycorquin is that because so many
people get better
you know the control group might be 99
of the people get better
then you give hydroxycorquin to this
same group and you might get 99.5
it's it's going to be a difficult thing
to actually prove in trials
that you get a benefit it sounds like in
some of the sicker patients where you
had a mortality
um you know where you had a 25 mortality
down to 15
that does sound significant now you're
getting into the sicker patients with
the outpatient studies
one of the critiques is that so many
people get better naturally
how are you proven that it is
statistically significant and what comes
to my mind is
sort of like when we wanted to prove
that aspirin taking an aspirin a day was
good to prevent heart attacks
it took like 10 years and 10 000 you
know people in the study because it was
it was just hard to show the differences
of whether an aspirin worked or not
um i think the same thing is true with
either hydroxychloroquine or ivermectin
in an outpatient
setting is that because so many people
get better on their own the converse is
when you're really sick
because almo because it's hard to get to
to treat people who are very sick it's
hard to prove that anything works when
people are very sick
but i guess what i'd like to do is open
it for the panel one by one
to explain how we answer the
critique that mostly paper people are
getting better anyway so how you've
proven that your treatment works
in a group of people who didn't go to
the hospital so that you're selecting
out actually for the people
who may well been you know did you
prevent them from getting seriously sick
or have you selected out as your patient
pool because they're outpatient
tending to be people are gonna get
better why don't we uh we'll start with
those who are here we'll start with dr
oscar and then we'll go to dr corey
let me quick interject because we have
such low participation take whatever
time you
you have for whatever questions you have
dr thank you very much
senator paul and i appreciate your your
introduction i'm not here as a
politician i'm here as a trader
uh i'll be very practical and i'll defer
to dr corey
from his experience as an intensivist my
clinical approach to patients are that
they have symptoms that i treat them
early
and i typically risk stratify patients
getting
ldh levels lymphocyte counts uh and
other
other blood panels uh whenever possible
uh
i when i've used hydroxychloroquine i've
and and oftentimes cybermechtin
i've had patients go to the hospital if
i didn't have
an ekg or another good assessment and
i've always
clinically evaluated the patients i've
treated but i risk stratified them
you you may or may not know a
husband-and-wife couple that i know dr
john senator johnson knows
who i treated the wife and not the
husband because i didn't deem the
husband to be sick enough
to warrant treatment although perfectly
safe too but his wife was much sicker
so i think this has to be some degree
left in a discretionary clinicians
in terms of the data i provided uh the
clerk of this committee
ms kilbride uh uh uh pdfs
of numerous clinical trials on many of
these drugs
uh not limited but including uh
hydroxychloroquine iremectin
uh vitamin d zinc and a few other uh
medications and those trials are there
but
the fact that we've had third world
countries second world countries
that have been more innovative and have
outperformed us in terms of survival
i think is something that warrants uh
questioning and it's one has to wonder
if our bloated
uh research academic bureaucracy has
been excuse me has been more of a
hindrance
than a help uh during this healthcare
crisis but i'll
turn this to whomever i hope that's
satisfactory dr corey senator paul
i appreciate your question and it's it's
critical the the the
the content of your question which is
how can we tell when something's working
when
many patients get better and there's
only one answer that
and we know what that is and it's one of
the the central tenets of science which
is you need a control group
you need to have a group that is
comparable to those that you treat
and then you compare them to those that
you don't treat what i am
trying to message today is in our
manuscript
we now have 11 randomized
controlled trials every one of those
controlled trials
show that in the ivermectin treated
group
lives are saved there's less need for
hospitalization there's less
transmission less case counts
it is a fundamentally and powerfully
effective therapy against covet 19.
we need the nih to review these data we
have the data
let me say the amount of patients in
those randomized control trials the 11
trials
total nearly 4 000 with over half
treated with ivermectin let's remind
ourselves
that the treatment of covert 19
fundamentally changed after the recovery
trial was announced
in june that was a trial of 6 000
patients
2 000 were treated with steroids and it
showed the dramatic and life-saving
properties of corticosteroids
almost overnight the treatment of covert
19
changed as a result of that trial that
was the recovery trial
i am presenting a paper today with more
patients treated with ivermectin
with larger magnitudes of benefit than
the recovery trial
i will maintain ivermectin should be the
standard of care of this disease
based on these data it's not my opinion
it's the data
we have the data if you give anyone else
a placebo
based on the data that's in our
manuscript i
i believe that would be malpractice and
you will lead
to the to the heightened risk of death
no more placebo is needed so the 11
studies are inpatient or inpatient and
outpatient they
they vary so the randomized control
trials it i i almost can't describe what
this data shows
people need to read the manuscript we
have four randomized control trials in
prophylaxis
each and every one highly statistically
significant
patients or people even citizens healthy
citizens on ivermectin
do not get cold and you're comparing it
to placebo in these studies you're
considering yes
so in in in the prophylaxis studies
alone which is four
they took covet 19 patients who tested
positive for covert 19
they identified their household members
they gave them ivermectin
so they had a whole group of household
contacts of covet 19 patients who took
ivermectin
the other households they didn't give
ivermectin every single randomized
controlled trial
shows that in the households that were
on ivermectin
drastically reduced rates of
transmission the
they did not the households did not get
sick you can protect
people from this disease with ivermectin
that's just the prophylaxis trials
the outpatient trials the outcome tested
was how many people were positive
turned out positive were positive or how
many people got symptoms
and they were drastically statistically
significant
these are and from multiple centers and
countries around the world
that's just the prophylaxis we also have
trials on early outpatient
as well as hospital the most dramatic is
the hospital
each almost every single one we have
four large randomized controlled trials
in the hospital all
statistically significant reductions
mortality dr
reiter has a large observational control
trial from uh broward county and he's
here on the panel today
in his trial he also showed the same the
patients who got ivermectin
died at far less rates and opponents of
using ivermectum
have they responded to these critiqued
these has there been a generalized
argument that they make or is in silence
so the opponents again i want to call
attention to
the nih and their recommendation i don't
say that they're an opponent
they made their last recommendation on
ivermectin on august
27th which is either 10 years ago or
four months ago i don't know which
august 27th
this was their recommendation we
recommend against the use of ivermectin
outside of clinical trials
that recommendation was based on expert
opinion
only there was no data to recommend or
recommend against it was an
expert opinion well i'll be happy to
join with the chairman in
sending a letter to try to get an
evaluation um if we could go to the same
question if we've got time
you should actually get better also
start with dr reiter
thank you for allowing me to speak so
to clarify something people talk about
asymptomatic patients
but i have kind of stopped using that
nomenclature i call them pre-symptomatic
patients we do not know offhand
which one of these asymptomatic patients
are going to develop severe disease
and become symptomatic that is problem
number one
problem number two when
i put in my written testimony and also
during my early testimony i talk about
the early intervention and treatment
to decrease viral shedding and viral
transmission in the home setting
and that is currently believed to be
the largest numbers of people getting
infected or getting infected in the home
setting
so that means a 20 or 30 year old may do
fine
but not comes christmas there is a
family meeting
and that asymptomatic individual now
infects other family members including
their 70 80 90 year old grandma
and now we have a real problem what we
do know about ivermectin
is that it literally destroys the virus
in most people within 48 hours
so hence you take somebody who is
asymptomatic but the carrier with the
risk of transmission
and you essentially stop that right in
their tracks so you don't
have an issue about that person now
contaminating
other people down the line or you
significantly decrease that risk
so that is really even a very different
spin on that question that was asked
now to continue as far as the data
you're right senator it will be
difficult
my team currently has a study in place
we have
the protocols written ready to go the
only limiting factor was to get funding
i've tried everywhere
getting the funding is extremely
difficult what we need to do
is a large study a large randomized
control study
to confirm the findings to
prove to the naysayers you know what
here is your golden standard
now the study that i did was a
observational study but it was
propensity matched that is the highest
standard for a non-randomized control
trial
and even there it shows tremendous
benefit
you spoke about the reduction in the
overall mortality from 25 donkeys 15
well if you look at the overall
mortality in people with severe lung
involvement
that went from 81 down to 39 percent
that is in that is even a more dramatic
decrease
in even these more severe uh individuals
it is a safe drug
a track record that is phenomenal 3.7
billion doses administered so i think we
need to do those studies with the help
of the nih cdc or any one of those
regulatory agencies
a study like that could be implemented
within 30 days
within another 30 days from that we
could have collected all the data
within another two three weeks from that
we should be able to have answers
if things are moved forward through the
regulatory
agencies we couldn't have our answers
before the strategy
even worsens dr balboni
great thank you and thank you senator
paul for the question i think uh
i'll speak uh to the trials that we're
running for by the peer of your broad
spectrum antiviral
targeting rna dependent rna polymerase
we're running currently two
large placebo-controlled randomized
phase three trials in the outpatient
setting
early treatment and close exposure
prophylaxis in addition
there are two phase twos one at stanford
in the outpatient setting
and and in long-term care as well there
are observational studies with with
thousands
of data points and hundreds of smaller
trials having been run in many countries
around the world
we need to develop hybrid trial
methodologies to combine
all of these traditional rcts and
observational study designs to gather
real world evidence
for for the regulators if we don't cool
all of these data we're going to see
kovid 19 in our rear view mirror we're
going to quickly forget about it and all
of these potential treatments are going
to fall by the wayside
so i agree with you we need to gather
the data it will be
large populations but we have to make
that commitment the only way we can make
these
these these studies work is a true
public-private partnership
single companies as we've heard don't
have the ability or the incentive to run
these
trials that revere by the way is off
patent we're doing that
we're doing this at risk as a consortium
um there's very little support for this
kind of work
and as soon as it falls away we've got
to be beholden to our shareholders and
our boards
in the meantime as a physician i'm
trying to do the right thing for
patients
we need the assistance we need
government help this has to be a whole
of government approach and
a commitment to going beyond this
immediate problem which is pressing it
in our faces
but to do the right thing over the long
haul to gather the data
to uh to silence uh to silence the the
criticisms of
of these kinds of studies multiple small
studies
won't work as you correctly point out um
so
this is what we need gather the data
bundle it together and and make this
available for future outbreaks and the
last thing i'll say
is that as part of our trials it is true
that if we were to look only at
mortality
data these trials would be unacceptably
large it would take too long to run
we have been working with the regulators
to look at time to resolution of
symptoms similar to what was done with
also tamivir or tamiflu we believe that
that is a a stepwise approach
but it but it's taking uh too long uh
uh to to do this we don't have a whole
of government approach
um to to this problem and so i so i ask
the committee
um those present and those who have
decided not to ask questions
to just please internalize this message
we need a whole government approach
similar to what was done with vaccines
to gather the data to do exactly what
you said which is uh get to these large
populations to show a difference
so next doctor orion i see senator holly
on the computer so we're going to check
see whether he wants to
ask questions but dr orient you want to
answer that question
senator paul that's an excellent
question that certainly applies to all
types of research
i would say if you have a really sick
patient in a sense you have
a controlled uh historical control in
that patient if the patient is
going downhill and you do something in
the patient gets better
then that that is evidence that maybe
you did something right on the other
hand if
a patient is doing pretty well and you
do something that patient suddenly gets
worse
then you have to be worried that you
might have caused that problem
if you have a patient a bunch of
patients who are healthy
and they're going to do well no matter
what
then then i guess you really need to
have a large study and it looks like
with ivermectin they
they have done that there there of
course many confounding variables
and and then there are the ethical
questions if you have something that's
going to protect your grandma
if it works and and doing nothing is
going to put your grandma at risk then
then are you engaging some kind of human
sacrifice to
to use a placebo at what point does that
become the thing
some people have even suggested that
maybe the rct is
outdated and we should be looking at
other statistical approaches
like bayesian analysis so that we can
get good data without running into this
ethical
ethical dilemma and deal with with the
need maybe to have combination therapies
and to deal with confounding variables
dr bhattacharya
thank you senator paul for that question
i mean i think that the
the gist of your question is is right
that this when you have an outcome
that's relatively rare
uh yeah you what you need is very very
large samples
in order to test uh whether the the
and a control group to test whether the
treatment actually works
um you can get some indication with
observational studies uh
there are the difficulties that that the
treatment is not randomly assigned
um but there are statistical methods to
to address that
uh and the great advantage of
observational studies is that with these
statistical methods
correcting for this sort of a selection
bias and treatment
you actually can get very large samples
relatively inexpensively
so there's a procedure here i think we
could follow uh i mean we could we could
use uh data sets like the
medicare claims data uh other other
claims data sets and other other
other readily available large-scale data
sets to to
check for for uh in sort of
well-designed observational settings
uh facial studies to see if uh there's
some promising
you know some promise to the kinds of
treatments that people are thinking
about you could do this for many many
many
treatments in principle um uh you know
lots of people with different ideas
can check and then use that to inform
what
where the large trial should be run i
mean i think that's that's one
procedure that there are others one
potentially could follow but the
the the the key thing i want to get
across is this is that it is possible if
you just choose to do it
um and then the incentives to do this
have have not been great
and as as a result we have much less
information than we probably should have
about the effectiveness of various uh
treatments uh that you know they
proposed
that we should that we should have had
by this time uh in part also i think
that's been driven by this
group think that you mentioned that uh
that has decided that uh there's only
a small set of things that are going to
work even before any of the evidence has
been evaluated um
i think all of that is to be regretted i
think we have to we have to
go back to our the principles we know
about how sound
science works um we have to we have to
look at uh
you have to do control groups you have
to do uh studies
but you have to have the incentives to
run those studies or else they're not
going to get done
so senator holly are you there
but we'll check with his uh with his
staff you know one thing i
i think we lose in these discussions
about observational versus
iran control studies is the the
difference between
a pandemic situation and a non-pandemic
situation
when you've got these off-the-shelf
drugs have been
prescribed safely for decades it's kind
of like why not give it a shot i mean
this
it's a com it should be a completely
different mindset
and we just went the other way so we do
we have senator hawley
thanks for joining the hearing go ahead
yeah thank you mr chairman
um and thanks for holding this hearing
uh doctor about to teriya if i could
first of all am i pronouncing your name
right is it anybody
just fine thanks okay thank you that's
very indulgent of you
um i i want to ask you about some of the
points that you made
in your written testimony uh which i
thought were quite striking
about the challenges of mitigation
strategies particularly
mitigation strategies that involve
lockdowns full lockdowns which of course
we experienced in
virtually every part of the country
certainly my home state earlier this
year and that many have been advocating
as a mitigation strategy again now
you write about the the data uh that uh
the the consequences of social isolation
and the deteriorating mental health that
is associated with these lockdowns i was
particularly struck by the cdc data that
you cite
that says let me get this right that one
in four
young adults seriously considered
suicide this past june when much of the
country
was locked down that's a really stunning
number and these impacts that you talk
about in your testimony are really
stunning so can you
speak to the challenges that maybe young
people in particular but but all
americans face
from lockdowns as a mitigation strategy
i i think i think lockdowns as a
mitigation strategy are a failure of
a map policy imagination and they have
been had absolutely devastating effects
humans are not meant to live in
isolation and that's that's the main
focus of the lockdown strategies
um now i think there are some folks who
are at higher risk from this disease as
i said older people some people with
chronic conditions
and so for instance 40 of deaths that
happen in nursing homes there we
actually do need to do
some sort of isolation but we have to be
careful there as well
uh 20 there's been a 20 increase in
dementia related deaths in nursing homes
apart from covid there's a the key the
key failure i think is
a failure of public health to recognize
that there's dangers
other than covet heart disease
psychology the psychological distress to
young people is devastating
we basically made them feel guilty uh
for even
for doing normal young people things uh
i mean and as
a result it's it's had as you can see
one in four seriously considered suicide
that number is absolutely shocking i
mean i think it just shocked the
imagination of everyone listening
into thinking creatively about policy
alternatives to lockdown
the lockdown should be a very very
last-ditch effort
not the the thing that we decided we
should do all the time
i noticed that now even the world health
organization which i
say is a body in which i place very
little trust
um and for which given its conduct and
this pandemic i have very little respect
but nonetheless even the who i believe
has now said that mass lockdowns as a
mitigation strategy
are they don't recommend them i mean
quite the contrary that they think the
consequences some of which you've just
outlined from these lockdowns
are devastating yeah i mean i think
there's an estimate
that the that the un put out uh in april
actually i think uh
saying that that there were 130 million
people at risk of starvation as a
consequence of the economic damage from
the epidemic
um i mean these are lives 130 million i
mean that's
that's about you know two orders of
magnitude more than the number of people
have died from kovac 19.
um and to not account for that in our
policy response i think is it is utterly
irresponsible
can you talk to me a little bit about
some of the other health care effects
associated with um lockdowns and
decisions to cancel elective surgeries i
know in
my home state of missouri many hospitals
uh
canceled elective surgeries back in the
spring
trying to prepare based on the data at
the time for what they thought would be
an absolutely massive surge
and even now as we're seeing cases
rising quite significantly across the
country and again in my home state
a number of hospitals as a precaution
have have curbed elective surgeries and
can some cases delay them which i
totally understand but
help us speak to if you could the the
issues that come
with the problem of deferred health care
and when you have
again especially in a lockdown situation
when you have many
tens of thousands of americans millions
of americans may be deferring what would
otherwise be fairly routine health care
procedures
health care visits what is the
cumulative effect of that over weeks and
months
uh has it built up we're going to be
paying the total for that
for gent for for a very long time just
just to take one example that's
striking to me mammography mammograms to
check for breast cancer
declined by i think something over 80
percent nationwide
what's the consequence of that many many
women
who would have been diagnosed with
earlier stage breast cancers now will
come in with late stage
breast cancers in the in the next year
uh
and we've actually had made a lot of
progress in in reversing mortality for
for
uh for breast cancer and other cancers
in in the in the last decade
um that's going to get reversed with
with 100 certainty as
as as basic preventative measures
colonoscopies
mammography had gone by the wayside
because of covet
i mean i think it's it's i mean i should
just be clear because of the coveted
lockdowns
um i think that the uh public health
should think about
all of public health all of health not
simply one disease it's a public health
not just about infection control
i think that's been a major mistake that
we've made all through this uh through
this pandemic
very good thank you for that dr corey
could i just ask you a question or two
about social media you wrote in your
testimony i noticed that one of the
barriers to using already existing
therapeutics
uh whatever they may be is an array of
them uh has been
social media and and you say that your
pages in particular have been repeatedly
blocked
on facebook i wonder if you could just
elaborate on your experience with
facebook or any other social media on
this topic
yeah you know i i want to try to be
respectful because i i think the
intention
is correct the execution
is unfortunately damaging which is my my
guess at what the social media outlets
in particular it's facebook um is that
they want to cut down
on misinformation right which is many
doctors are out there claiming
x y and z work in this disease
the challenge is you're also silencing
those of us who are
expert reasoned researched
and and extremely knowledgeable and so
at my group our facebook page and again
i i repeat we are some of the most
uh highly published uh physicians in our
specialty
we've spent you know decades in academic
medicine we're we're not just some
random doctor but
our group every time we mention
ivermectin we've been put
in facebook jail currently as of this
moment
our facebook page is shut down to the
point where we cannot post anything
and we've asked the senator for help in
that because we're trying to disseminate
uh
expert opinion uh heavily researched
insights into the therapeutics of this
disease and we are unable to do that on
social media
and what what what reason
dr corey what reason have they given if
any
uh for putting you in facebook jail i i
don't know that that we've gotten
specific reasons but
the best that we can tell is that we
were mentioning ivormectin so any claims
to a simple solution
and i by the way i'm going to stand by
my professional reputation my decades in
medicine
and i'm going to tell you that i believe
not only i believe
but my group of doctors and there's at
least nine of us
who co-authored this manuscript we are
telling the world
this is the solution to covet 19 and it
can be implemented rapidly
however social media does not want to
hear that from doctors and
i don't blame them because otherwise
you're going to have doctors coming
along and saying you know
i don't know soda water or this is the
next solution so i understand the intent
however um i just wish uh
some credibility would be applied to us
and and and
i did i don't know how to solve that
answer because i i do think
misinformation is a problem it is a
deep and significant problem this in
this pandemic
however uh we are not propagators of
misinformation
is facebook uh staffed with expert
epidemiologists and
infectious disease researchers to your
knowledge not to my knowledge
certainly not no i mean should facebook
be the arbiter of
of what counts as medical research in
your opinion
of course i don't think that they should
be the arbiters but i but i i'm trying
to be fair and i
i do think they their intent is to
protect people from misinformation
however they are also blocking good
information
it's it's a very hard filter to put on
and i and i
i can understand their challenge i just
wish they did
better at it right well thank you dr
corey for uh thank you for your work
and thank you for sharing that
unfortunately this is a pattern that we
see with facebook
and the other social media giants which
have now decided that they will be the
arbiters of all information
news journalism and the rest in the
united states and that they will
determine
what counts as accurate reliable news
research and everything else despite
usually
having zero expertise in any of these
areas
and by the way with zero desire for the
american public
that they should be deciding what we
read what we consume what we learn about
what we share
it's really unbelievable mr chairman uh
thank you very much for holding this
hearing
well thank you senator holly for
participating i want to go to dr ryder
who's treated patients both in hospital
and
in hospital and also as an outpatient
just to describe in human terms
what happens to a covid patient i think
it is
one of the more heartbreaking aspects of
the disease that
and quite honestly it's one of the
reasons i know people that will not get
tested
because they don't want to become a
coveted patient because they don't want
to be separated from their family but
can you just describe what's happened
and
and how we are you know people are dying
alone
and is that is does is is that
does that continue to be necessary but
just describe what happens when you have
somebody going to the hospital take it
from there
yes sir thank you senator so let me talk
about the specific patient of a specific
example because that's very vivid in my
mind
talk as loud as you can this is a lady
that came in she was in her 50s
no significant medical problems i
believe she had
slight hypertension and diabetes but
everything was very well controlled
um the lady was initially diagnosed we
called it when she presented
and was on room air within a few hours
she ended up on two liters worth of
oxygen
and that's the point at which i got
consulted to help with her management
over the course of the next 24 hours
this lady went from two liters of oxygen
all the way up to 50 percent of oxygen
that is a very
very rapid decline at the time the
hospital
was in lockdown meaning there were no
visitors allowed into the hospital so
this lady
knew that things were going very badly
for her um
the medical staff was limiting access to
the rooms because we had very limited
ppe supplies
so there she was with the disease that
she was well aware of was quite critical
with no family at bedside very limited
interaction with healthcare workers and
nurses
entering that room and
i was there looking at her i'm like this
is bad news based on my experience this
lady would be facing near
certain intubation and back in april
intubation meant a 90
chance of dying so i call her son up
and uh gets a ipad into the room so they
can facetime
and have a discussion that's the point
that which the sun broke down in tears
it's like doctor you've got to do
something for her you got to you got to
doctors always have something they can
do
i'm like sir with all the respect i have
nothing else to offer
luckily my wife who is also a doctor
dr sapillowicz writer had just read the
article about
dr wagstaff and australia the day before
and
um you know as the patient's family was
pleading with me i'm like you know what
we have this we have this one hope
i don't know what to do with this there
is no clinical data the dosing in that
trial is not something i can administer
to humans it's toxic
and then it was like but it has other
indications right i'm like yes there is
and then we started talking about other
indications they said you know what give
it a shot
try please i beg of you try so i got
informed consent from him
informed consent from her administered
the drug
and allowed to establish that
connectivity between that family
luckily that lady did very well she did
not get intubated she went up to 90
oxygen but subsequently improved it was
discharged to home maybe a week later
but you see that social isolation where
those people are away from family
and even today today visitors
are allowed back into the hospital but
they are not
allowed into the coveted rooms that
means that those
patients are away from family and
because of
all the measures that healthcare workers
need to take
even now we still have a policy of
limiting entry into the room for example
the nurse will group all the lab draws
and all the medications
and try to enter the room maybe three or
four times a day at most
uh the residents which are part of the
institution or ask not to enter the room
um there's going to be one or two
physicians that are going to do the
physical exam which is taken over by the
other physicians
usually i'm one of those physicians that
has to enter the room on all these
patients and expose myself
but once again it is very very isolating
for these people
uh we now know that besides all the
medical problems that covet causes the
kidney problems the heart problem the
lung problems
we also know that it creates tremendous
amount of problems with mental status
these people their mind is not quite
right
and we have seen this a tremendous
amount of anxiety
so yes it has been emotionally draining
both for the patients their families and
frankly for healthcare workers as myself
you know
i have a young family i have a young
wife and children and at the end of the
day
i want to go home and be safe and that's
why i have become such a major proponent
of early treatment because with
early treatment i will not expose the
healthcare workers including myself and
my staff
unnecessarily to these people now
admitted to the hospital with
more advanced disease and that's why i
feel it's so critical to have that early
intervention
because we do know that treatment works
much better earlier on than later on
and even later on you can see on my data
that i published
that the results are quite staggering so
dr ryder you just made a pretty pretty
convincing case from my standpoint
of why we should concentrate on early
treatments because if we can
we avoid that type of human toll
dr orient one of the reasons i contacted
or got in contact with you became aware
of you was
through dr lee vliet who was early
advocating
early treatment in particular with
hydroxychloroquine
and your organization allowed me to get
i think it's like
1300 or 1700 doctors very quickly
signing a letter that we sent to the
president united states encouraging
uh you know doing something to allow
doctors to have access to these types of
drugs to use their off
label prescription rights but i think
one thing that always impressed me about
your organization aaps was it's pretty
simple mission statement so
can you first describe that then also
what you're hearing from that network of
doctors
that have the courage and compassion to
treat patients early
and basically and you know answer my my
question that i asked dr reiter about
you know what is happening these covet
patients and is there is there a better
approach
well aaps was founded in 1943 to
preserve private medicine
and that means the physician is working
for the good of his patients
like it says on the oath of hippocrates
not for the good of the organization or
society or the political party
or the advancement of science but each
individual patient is the doctor's first
priority
and the doctor has to have the
authority to go along with his
responsibility to that patient
to look into the best best methods uh to
communicate with his colleagues um and
sometimes
or a lot of times you just have to guess
about what's the best thing to do for
your patient and
to keep a careful watch on on what works
best
we found that of physicians in
independent practice
are able to do this but once a doctor
has an
employer or he has a managed care plan
where he's restricted to what's on the
drop-down menu
then he his hands are really tied
if if the nih is the is the authority
that their
employer respects then then if he goes
outside
those rules no matter how much his
patient needs it
he's putting his uh his life at risk and
it's becoming more and more it's we used
to worry about
um about practice liability but that's a
minor thing compared with
being period by your hospital in a way
just to get rid of you that destroys
your whole
career forever or of being before the
licensure board
because you deviated from the standard
of care
which used to be determined by what
doctors in the similar situation
rational well-trained people would do
but now
it's dictated more and more by single
authorities from on high
who's whose opinions keep just getting
carried on along like the ama or the
arizona medical association
i'm learning about ivermectin here the
arizona medical association army county
medical society
the ama will say nothing about this and
you ask about
what are doctors doing and the answer is
well
nothing that's not not recommended by by
the fda
so for a patient to have an independent
doctor
who is not under quite so much severe
restrictions on what he what he can do
is extremely important occasionally a
patient will tell me well
i begged and pleaded with the hospital
to do this
for my my person with my patient my
husband who was dying please please
we'll give them some intravenous vitamin
c
and sometimes the patient's suggestion
works i mean it doesn't always
but if the doctor's afraid that he dare
not do something that's even very safe
or that's even being critically trialled
or has been reported in the literature
even if a long time ago that he will
lose his job then he has every incentive
to say well
there's nothing more that i can do
so keeping keeping this this option open
for patients
is extremely important thank you dr
orient
um you know i i championed right to try
and you know dr reiter basically that's
what
you you practiced in i mean you had a
patient there
you had to do something with that
patient and the patient's son
begged you to do something and he did
something i think that that
is exactly your right and and we
certainly are seeing
a different type of medical
establishment where we have fewer
doctors
practicing medicine and more associated
with these
hospitals where they follow protocols
which makes perfect sense
but in a pandemic you have you have to
think outside the box you have to do
other things dr balboni i want to ask
you
because i i thought our phone
conversation on sunday was was pretty
interesting
you've you've been you've been in the
fda you've been
a physician in department of defense
you've been in government
but now you're you're on the outside um
i really want to ask you two questions
one can you describe
why government doesn't have the
incentive
to run these trials we know the private
sector doesn't
they they cost millions and millions of
dollars
and if it's a generic drug there's no
incentive other than
in government and it should be the nih
or the cdc their fda
that advocates for all citizens for all
patients regardless of
you know the financial incentive but but
to look at repurposing drugs
can you describe why that did not occur
because one of the things we talked
about
uh is you know we had these drugs in our
tool kit for a pandemic
you know i think dr fauci talked about
hydroxychloroquine
um the drug that your company is trying
to go through trial now
that was kind of in the toolkit it was
designed for pandemics
and all of a sudden we hit covet it's
like that toolbox
drawer was shut and locked and we
ignored it so can you just kind of
describe that that process and and the
lack of incentives
sure and and great great question um and
i'll and i'll try and do so
with the uproar the utmost respect for
um
uh my colleagues and former colleagues
in government because i think at the end
of the day
people are trying to do the right thing
and and i have to say that
um and sometimes it doesn't always work
out that way into your question about
why
we're working on fab appearability i
first saw that as part of the ebola
outbreak
in 2014 and it showed an effect in
treating um ebola
and then everyone kind of forgot about
it and the
the pressure to move quickly went away
uh it was uh it's approved for pandemic
flu in japan
it's approved for kobit 19 in india and
russia it's it's it's
likely to be approved in japan for covet
19
imminently the fda
is not moving as quickly although we're
having very just very fruitful
discussions with them
um i i think that um we are treating
unfortunately many of these products um
as if they were for chronic diseases
and that may work well in a non-pandemic
situation
and that's how that's the structure of
these organizations is to is to
review uh uh thoughtfully and take the
time
to look at to look at all the data and
again i'm not suggesting we don't do
that
but in addition to that we have to push
these agencies uh there has to be a
forcing function for change
and when under stress um i think they
did they they
they fall back on what they know which
is uh uh
uh reviewing and approving um uh
drugs like cardiovascular drugs which
which are which
they can take more time with so i i
think it there needs to be um
both a forcing function for um uh
uh supporting their efforts to move
outside of what is tried and true
in their review process and i think you
as as a committee and as
as politicians have your hands on that
lever
whether it's policy or law there needs
to be a forcing function to move them
out of the ways that they do things
which again work in a non-pandemic
situation i would point to two things
senator
public law um i worked on that as
when i was with inside the dod um that
that was a law signed uh uh into effect
in 2017
which mandates that the dod and fda hold
discussions and talks around regulated
products
that are of particular interest to the
warfighter and it puts them on an
accelerated approval track
um it doesn't cut corners but it allows
the regulators to devote resources to
those kinds of accelerated discussions
i would also point to a very recent
development and politics notwithstanding
um it shouldn't matter
a very pragmatic approach to doing the
same kinds of
photos this morning
yeah now let's go business after because
i gotta see what the man's gonna be
you know
you know i don't think i i don't think
he gave a [ __ ]
like tearing the process apart
so i'm pretty calm no points
wow
[Music]
nice to meet you yes nice to finally
meet you do you know who's sitting here
look at me oh courtney okay great thank
you
i know they don't quite match i like it
so i thought it was cold i wanted to
heat things up a little bit
it's cold out there you're right
anything it's cold walking across that
bridge from the parking lot
the culture
uh